he's
back it truly is a major thing i'm
very happy john cena made an epic
surprise return to the wwe
during monday's money in the bank
pay-per-view event
seemingly throwing his hat in the ring
for the upcoming summerslam title
man this feels pretty good during the
final moments of the show
just after roman reigns defeated edge to
retain his universal championship title
john's iconic theme music kicked in and
the 13-time wwe champion
stormed the ring and confronted roman
with his signature
you can't see me hand gesture just as
the show was about to end
oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but fans won't have to wait long to see
what he's up to
tonight i just wanted to come out here
and let roman reigns know that i was
back and i certainly wanted to come out
here
to let all of you know that i'm back the
wwe posted this clip to social media on
monday
to announce that john will also be
appearing on monday night raw
to share the next steps of his comeback
so many of the wwe universe have a
litany of questions who what when where
why amongst others well i'm not going to
make you wait for answers
i am kicking off monday night raw to
tell you
my motivation and you're not gonna want
to miss it e.t caught up with the 44
year old suicide squad star
earlier this summer ahead of the release
of his latest blockbuster f9
and the actor said he drew on his time
in the ring for those
big action movie moments and his intense
showdowns with vin diesel
fighting dom toretto in the fast and the
furious
is like being in the main event of
resume you get thrust in there with a
marquee talent on a blockbuster
franchise you're on the main stage in
the grandest stage of them all
you have to deliver meanwhile john's ex
nikki bella
and her twin sister brie recently teased
their own return to the ring during a
chat with e.t
are there conversations about making an
official return
to wrestling so we we definitely talk
about it
now that birdie's four and we were
talking about when the boys get a little
older too
to have your kids watch you do what we
used to do
to get in that ring would be really
special for us the bells are definitely
gonna make a comeback we don't know
exactly when but we said we have one
more run in us and we'd really love to
do it yeah but we are starting
like i know for me like definitely
starting that preparation
yeah like i want to train hard for it
when i when we come back
like i want i want to change my style in
the ring a little bit but i want to make
a statement right
and so i realized that i have to start
that now yeah
nikki was recently inducted into the wwe
hall of fame as one half of the bella
twins and during her speech
she surprised fans by thanking her ex
john
for his support throughout her career
and to john thank you for teaching me a
lot about this business and truly
helping me find my fearless side
i look at my career and i know that
wasn't just because of me
it was gree it was the bella army it was
the producers
all the people that believed in me and
john was a big part of that
he really helped me be that fearless
side and showed me a part of that
world that i never saw before and
i think just because you have breakups
or whatever it may be doesn't mean you
can't like
thank those people and just truly be so
grateful for the help that they had